à l'heure de la prise de conscience
mondiale du réchauffement climatique un
projet pétrolier démesurée de total en
ouganda fait polémique une installation
d'un autre siècle est planifié 400 puis
à forer pour produire deux cent seize
mille barils par jour pour un
investissement de plus de 10 milliards
de dollars le pétrole serait transportée
par un oléoduc chauffer géant le à coop
sur un trajet 2443 km le conseil des
ministre ougandais vient d'en valider le
principe plusieurs accords relatifs à ce
projet ont été signés le 11 avril
dernier
total energy la china national offshore
oil corporation se partagent cette
galette ainsi que les compagnies
pétrolières nationales d'ouganda et de
tanzanie cours environnemental de
l'exploitation estimés par an 33
millions de tonnes de co2 à titre de
comparaison le monde dans sa globalité
et mais plusieurs dizaines de milliards
de tonnes de co2 par an et l'aviation
quelques centaines de millions de tonnes
de co2 c'est dire à quel point ses
prévisions relatives aux projets de
total sont préoccupantes autre problème
environnemental les réserves de pétrole
ont été découvertes sous le lac albert
dans le parc naturel protégé des
martinson folle en ouganda et l'oléoduc
a cop devrait traverser césaire naturels
protégés en ouganda et en tanzanie
500 espèces d'animaux vivre au sein du
parc naturel et l'oléoduc passera sous
le nil dans des zones écologiquement
fragiles
en outre ce projet nécessite de déplacés
723 foyer des allégations d'intimidation
et de harcèlement sur deux représentants
des communautés locales ont été
transmises ils m'ont empêché d'aller sur
mes terres
les cultures étaient là ils nous ont
empêchés même et deuxième chose c'était
la pression et l'intimidation ça
indiqués du sont quatre rapporteurs
spéciaux des nations unies ont même
demandé des comptes à ce sujet au groupe
au gouvernement français ou candé et à
la filiale locale de total lo ng les
amis de la terre s'est d'ailleurs plaint
d'une collecte d'informations difficile
nos partenaires qui enquête sur le
terrain subissent des pressions pour les
empêcher d'accéder à la zone concernée
est entré en contact avec les
populations affectées voilà des années
que les ong se bat pour freiner ce
projet gigantesque est jugée
climaticides et anti environnementale
allianz top back up réuni une trentaine
d'associations parmi lesquels figurent
les amis de la terre extinction
rébellion ou encore oxfam de son côté
total affirme donner des garanties le
projet a été conçu de manière à
minimiser la surface occupée par les
installations temporaires et permanentes
qui représente une emprise au sol
inférieure à 0 05 % de la surface du
parc le groupe confirme également qu'il
s'engage à mettre en oeuvre des plans
d'action permettant de produire un
impact positif net sur la biodiversité
dans le cadre de la réalisation de ces
projets quoi qu'il en soit les fortes
émissions de co2 viennent en pleine
contradiction avec l'appel des deux
mille scientifiques engageant les
gouvernements du monde entier à adopter
et mettre en oeuvre de toute urgence un
traité de non prolifération des
combustibles fossiles pour ne pas
dépasser 1,5 degrés de réchauffement
climatique plus de 80% des réserves
fossiles identifiées devraient restées
inexploitées face au tollé généré par
ces impacts environnementaux et
climatiques potentielles plusieurs
banques se sont retirés du projet dont
la société générale bnp paris et le
crédit agricole en france six ong ont
assigné le groupe total en justice en
considérant la loi relative au devoir de
vigilance des multinationales cette loi
de 2017 les oblige à prévenir les
atteintes graves envers les droits des
humains et l'environnement chez les
sous-traitants et fournisseurs étrangers
le tribunal de commerce ne sera jugé
prochainement cette affaire